hello and welcome everyone I'm James
Murphy and welcome to M coding where we
try to get just a little bit better
programming every episode
here's a trap that every single python
programmer will fall for at some point
in their career
there's pretty much no setup all I've
got is a small class with a class
variable count a getter and a Setter
we create an instance of the class and
print the count just as a control
then instead of using our Setter we
manually reach in and try to change the
count and then we print it
couldn't get much simpler of an example
than that right
so what do you think it'll print when I
run this main function
I'd give you a minute to think about it
but it seems like the answer should be
very obvious
the first print statement should print
zero that's the default class variable
and the second should print 42.
but when we actually run the code we see
Zero printed both times
but there's what 11 lines of code here
what could I possibly be doing wrong
if you don't already understand what's
going on the frustration of a bug like
this this is outrageous it's unfair how
can you be on the council and not be a
master no I'm not using a non-ascii
look-alike character or some other thing
to trick your eyes but yes it does have
something to do with the name of the
variable
in particular it has everything to do
with these two leading underscores
if you just name the variable count
instead of underscore underscore count
you would get the output that you're
probably expecting in the first place
so something funny is going on with the
underscores
but if I use the setter everything would
have worked fine
it was only when I tried to directly
regener the object that it didn't work
and to add to the confusion the value 42
is in there
when I directly set the value of the
count and I print it out by directly
grabbing its value we do see the 42.
it's just the call to get count that
still returns zero
to figure out what's going on let's
print the dictionary of this object
after setting the count with both
methods
very surprisingly if you're not aware of
this feature the dictionary contains two
different count variables
one of them is the one that we intended
to set
and the setter apparently set this
variable what and likewise the getter
appears to be getting that weird
variable not the variable that we set in
our code
well let me introduce you to the
questionable feature behind all of this
confusion private name mingling
basically if you're inside a class and
you name a variable with two leading
underscores then python will replace all
uses of that variable with a mangled
version of that variable
the reason for doing this is to sort of
support private access specifiers like
they have in other languages like C plus
and Java
suppose I'm building a GUI library and I
have a base widget class
I keep account of all the widgets and
increase it whenever I create a new one
I also use the count to give each widget
a unique ID
but there are going to be tons of
different widgets text boxes labels
buttons
but in some subclass like this button I
might also have some kind of account
in this case the buttons count means
something totally different
the button is counting how many times
it's been clicked
whereas the count in widget was like the
total number of widgets that had been
created before this button
but maybe I have a whole class hierarchy
of widgets
and I didn't write all of them
most of them were written by a mix of 10
different open source Developers
and of course anyone that uses the
library is free to create their own
widgets
because of this automatic private name
angling that happens there's no conflict
here
all uses of this count are automatically
replaced with this underscore widget
count
whereas all usages of this count get
replaced with button count
because of the private name angling the
author of the button class doesn't need
to know or care about the variables and
private implementation details of the
widget class
everything just works and there's no
conflict
at least that's how it's supposed to
work in theory
but in reality this picture comes with a
lot of asterisks
the first very important asterisk here
is that python does not have private
variables all variables in Python are
public
this private name angling just changes
the name of the variable it doesn't
actually prevent anyone from accessing
it
so if you know how name angling works
you can still reach inside the class and
change anything that you like
the intention of name angling is to
prevent accidental reusing of variables
not purposeful modifications by a
nefarious class author
the second asterisk is that the rules
for how name angling works and which
variables it applies to are pretty weird
python does this name angling if your
variable starts with two underscores
unless it also ends with two underscores
then it's not mangled
including if your variable is just two
or three underscores
and does this for all identifiers
including local variables so if you were
to look at the local variables of this
function you would see this
including for some reason Imports
unless the import has a dot in the name
and it doesn't just do this on self and
local variables it does it on any usage
of a variable name of this form
and the mangling is done based on the
class where the code is defined in not
the class of the object
so this statement will try to set this
underscore a version of the X variable
even if B isn't an instance of a
because this init function was defined
inside of the a class
it's going to use a here
but it doesn't just use the class name
if you add underscores to the beginning
of the class that doesn't change the
mingling so even if you have a bunch of
underscores at the beginning or more
realistically one underscore at the
beginning the mangled name will still
just have one underscore unless the
class name is only underscores then
nothing is ever mangled
if you're interested here's a python
implementation of how the mangling would
actually work based off of the given
class name and identifier
and if you're looking for the actual C
python implementation then you're
looking for this Pi mangle function
don't worry I'm not actually going to go
over the C code
but the one thing that I do want to take
away from this is actually the name of
the file this is in it's called
compile.c
that's right as if it wasn't already
confusing enough name angling actually
happens at compile time yes python is
compiled and it is also interpreted and
the name angling happens at compile time
so that means if I have this get count
example like at the beginning the usage
of count here isn't mangled because it's
not inside the class definition and we
see Zero just like at the beginning of
the video
but if I had defined this get count
function outside of the class and then
assigned it at runtime then because when
this function was compiled it was not
inside of a class this usage of
self-count doesn't get mangled
and therefore we see 21 instead of zero
so literally just moving where the
function was defined can change the
behavior
that means in any class depending on
this private name angling you can't use
many of the dynamic features of python
no dynamically created methods meta
classes or decorator magic that's not to
say those things can't work
but it just becomes incredibly
incredibly confusing in order to make it
work
if you want to stay safe and not worry
about it you're pretty much limited to
features of static languages
which is not completely bad in fact I
recommend that especially for larger
projects you self-impose a lot of the
restrictions that static languages force
on you but that's besides the point just
be aware if you're using mangle names
there is a very high chance that other
developers including yourself in the
future will be confused by what's going
on
in order to get a feel for when and how
python does this mangling and to verify
that it actually does happen at compile
time not at runtime I highly recommend
you check out compiler Explorer
or python shows you the bytecode output
of your module
you don't need to understand all the
bytecode in order to see what's going on
here
put in a recognizable constant so you
can find where that corresponds to in
the bytecode
very nearby notice we have this store
attribute
and there we see it a mangled name
you can see how if we don't meet the
requirements of a mangled name like just
having a single underscore then the
mingling doesn't happen
same thing if we had two trailing
underscores no mangling
we can use this to see that the mangling
still happens even if we're just using a
local variable
and we can see that it still happens
even if we have a deeply nested dotted
name
any use of this identifier will get
mangled as long as we're inside the
class
but if we're not inside a class look for
that constant here
then the name doesn't get mangled
please try this yourself check out all
the different cases of variable names
and class names and whatever and see for
yourself when and where the mangling
happens
my favorite absolutely cursed case of
this is this
of course I've literally never seen an
actual module that's prefixed with two
underscores but just so you can see what
the compiler does
we can see python does not mangle the
name of the module
but it does store the module under a
manual name
but if we just import a double
underscore module
then both the stored name and the
imported name are mangled and I guess
it's mostly just curiosity at this point
even I wouldn't do something this cursed
now that we understand that name angling
happens at compile time and after a
brief break to calm down
I just wanted to address what's usually
the most common question and that's how
does name mingling work with get adder
and set adder
mangle names are just names at runtime
so if you want to use get adder and set
Adder you need to just manually mangle
the name yourself
and additionally mingling does not apply
inside strings it only applies to
identifiers so think variable names and
dotted names
if you use get adder or set adder and
forget to mangle the name you're
probably going to get an error or set
the wrong attribute
so finally we need to address the
elephant in the room
and that is because of the confusion and
complexity of name angling do people
actually use private name angling in
practice and should you use private name
angling in practice
in my actual experience programming in
Python I pretty much never use this
and I pretty much never see it in anyone
else's code either
so what do I see
the most common thing that I see is
single underscore variable names
now different people will tell you that
a single underscore prefix means that a
variable should be treated as a private
variable or a protected variable or an
implementation detail and I'm not going
to argue about the technical definition
of what it should be called
suffice it to say that the convention
and the popular unspoken rule is that an
underscore prefect variable means don't
touch me
if the author of the class meant for you
to be able to change it they would give
you a way to do that often through
Getters and setters
rarely I do see this Dunder form of an
attribute to mean private
but actually I more often see that as a
public kind of magic attribute
more like a Dunder Len or a Dunder stir
these are typically not private it's
very common and expected for a class to
override these
but the problem is that these approaches
don't actually solve the original issue
that we had
remember we had a hierarchy of widgets
and we didn't want someone writing a
widget to have to understand the
implementation details and avoid the
variable names of all of the parent
classes
if I just use single underscore prefixes
in my variables that's certainly clear
to readers of my code that this is an
implementation detail you're not
supposed to touch it
but in order to know what all those
attributes are that I shouldn't touch I
need to end up reading all the source
code of all my parent classes
otherwise how do I know that my parent
class doesn't have their own don't touch
me variable
and so you have a choice a trade-off
you could use a single underscore and
force that every class that inherits
from you needs to know the
implementation details of your class or
you could use private name Angling
that way people that want to subclass
your class don't have to worry about any
of your implementation details but you
pay the price in terms of using this
confusing feature and you lose some of
that ability to use Python's Dynamic
capabilities
or and this is also a very questionable
idea you could manually mangle the names
subclasses don't have to know about your
implementation there's no unexpected
hidden or confusing side effects but
your code looks horrible and your
co-workers hate you honestly it's a
trade-off you need to just decide for
yourself
but full disclosure in the wild the most
common approach is to use the single
underscore and to just hope subclasses
don't clobber your implementation
details if you're very good about
keeping your classes defined as if they
were statically typed then you could
also write a letter rule to help you but
in any case go forth and decide for
yourself
as always thank you for watching and
making it to the end if you enjoyed my
video please do subscribe and if you
especially enjoyed it please consider
becoming a patron or donor thanks to all
my patrons and donors for their support
don't forget to slap that like button an
odd number of times I'll see you next
time